[Music]
foreign
here is a list of 10 deadly movie
monsters from the trench so to start off
Oceanic trenches are prominent long
topographic depressions of the ocean
floor they are typically 50 to 100
kilometers or 30 to 60 miles wide and
three to four kilometers or 1.9 to 2.5
miles below the level of the surrounding
Oceanic floor but it can be thousands of
kilometers in length so other sea
masters from other parts of the ocean
swimming around are not here in this
list just the ones from the deepest
parts of the ocean anyway let's get to
it
so starting off with the smallest we
have the trench in the movie Aquaman the
trench represents a subcategory of
atlanteans within the kingdom of the
same name the trench characterized by
their lack of sight the nighttime
activity and the Ferocious and monstrous
nature these subspecies have developed
distinct physiological traits that allow
them to survive at extreme depths
exceeding 2.5 kilometers beneath the
ocean floor they have adjusted to this
habitat by adapting away from sight as a
primary sense and have become nocturnal
they also exhibit an aversion to light
and typically avoid its presence
number two the Deep ones so in the movie
underwater aside from the alpha creature
there were also a swarm of other smaller
monsters well smaller relative to the
big Master but still twice or Thrice
taller than a normal man
these creatures although are named in
the movie are definitely the live action
movie adaptation of the deep ones
entities that serve and worship Cthulhu
they are arguably one of lovecraft's
most iconic monsters and it was great to
see them finally in the screens as
depicted in lovecraft's work the movie
also portrays them as human fish hybrids
of sorts
number three the ammonite in the movie
Mysterious Island a sephalopod
resembling an ammonite emerges from a
trench and attacks the characters of the
movie ammonites are a diverse group of
ancient cephalopods inhabiting the Earth
millions of years ago despite resembling
nautiluses ammonites were genetically
closer to squids and octopus the one
featured in The Mysterious Island movie
was of extraordinary size surprising all
known ammonite species comparable to a
giant squid the creature's body had a
resemblance to a large octopus spotted
too notably elongated tentacles akin to
those of a squid and also a hard shell
number four the octalus seen in the
movie The 1998 movie Deep Rising this
massive aquatic creature of mysterious
origin becomes a menace in the luxury
cruise ship called the arnautica octalus
possesses a multitude of lengthy slimy
tentacles each tip with a mouth and its
main body features a large mouth with
two prominent eyes the tentacles have
the Intriguing ability to seal their
mouths shut adding to the creatures
captivating and hazardous nature the
film speculates that the actalis could
hail from a confined and low-lying
expanse beneath the ocean floor commonly
referred to as a trench
number five the Kraken in the latest the
mag-2 the trench a variety of formidable
creatures Beyond just the Megalodons
made their appearance among them was a
particularly ominous and fear-inducing
cephalopod entity are properly referred
to as the Kraken here this colossal sea
creature boasts tracking yellowish eyes
with Slender pupils reminiscent of an
octopus gaze its bulbous head and a dark
gray black Hue coloration added to its
imposing presence while its long
tentacles are Dawn with suction cups
completed its menacing appearance the
Kraken engage in a fierce confrontation
with one of the Megalodons proving to be
a formidable adversary the outcome
though will not be spoiled here
number six the Meg in the movie The Meg
added sequel the habitat of the
Megalodon sharks is primarily set in the
Deep oceans particularly in the
unexplored depths of the Mariana's
Trench beneath the thermocline layer
whatever that is the Mariana's Trench is
one of the deepest parts of the world's
oceans and in the movie it is depicted
as an ancient and hidden ecosystem
teaming with undiscovered marine life
including the prehistoric Megalodon
sharks as adults the Megalodons appear
to be massive creatures over 100 feet or
30 meters in length and there were three
of them in the second movie along with
the one seen in the prologue and two
from the first movie so there is a total
of 7 Megs in between the two flicks in
this franchise
number 7 Gamera gamara is a gigantic
al-qaiju that debited in the 1965 movie
Gamora the giant monster he is often
stated as a rival to tohos Godzilla and
one of the most famous kaiji of all time
in the Hasty Trilogy Gamera is a
bioengineered earth Defender created by
Atlantis a kingdom found in the Deep
trenches of the Pacific Ocean there was
also an undersea graveyard containing
numerous other Gamera bones implying
that the atlanteans developed several
other specimens of this Kaiju this
monster resembles a huge heavily Armored
Turtle with a shell that can serve both
as a protective barrier and a weapon it
can also fly breathe fire and most of
all loves kids
number eight Cthulhu in the movie
underwater Cthulhu is reimagined as
massive organism devote of supernatural
abilities though or extraterrestrial
Origins the mere side of him doesn't
induce a Madness or Insanity as was seen
in the original World in the original
Cthulhu myths within the storyline of
the movie Cthulhu assumes the role of a
dominant creature overseeing a vast
underwater of spring swarm which could
potentially be the Deep ones though they
remain unnamed in the film cthulhu's
behavior is driven by a typical
animalistic instincts rather than
malevolence essentially serving as a
guardian of the Abyss this version of
Cthulhu and its zothian or swarm like
deep ones inhabit the Marianas Trench
number nine the Giant Octopus so from
the movie It Came from Beneath the Sea
the Giant Octopus is a massive
cephalopod of gaiju proportions that
emerged from the Pacific Ocean and
assaulted San Francisco in 1955. it
features six arms instead of the
customary age of the octopus this
colossal models is adept at swimming
freely and employs a jet propulsion
system enabling it to attain remarkable
speeds in open Waters while it was said
to typically reside in the Mindanao
trench within the Philippines Sea a
nuclear bomb testing in the region
forced it to relocate and then attacking
the cities in the North American Coast
and number 10 the karathan in the
Aquaman film The Hidden sea beneath the
trench is home to the karate this amends
on wise primordial sea creatures among
Earth's Mightiest beings for Ghana's
ages she has safeguarded the Trident of
atlan in the concealed depths eventually
she AIDS Aquaman in his mission to avert
conflict between the Surface realm and
the underwater domain joining forces
with him to oppose his half-brother or
Marius in the battle for Atlantis the
carton's appearance is reminiscent of a
colossal blend of a squid shrimp
crustacean and a dragon and as said
before the karatan is found in the
hidden sea beneath the trench so
essentially it is a trench monster
anyway I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel take
care fam